I think more so for me we're just
speaking about this before everyone came
in I think it's genuinely harder for men
because men have to graft no one's
coming to save a man I think society
would happily step over a man's corpse
you see it what 75% of homelessness is
men something like again similar stat
when it comes to Suicide I don't think
Society cares about men in fact people
probably laugh oh men are not having sex
oh it's just funny you know so there's
all these these different things you
know and I think and I because I do a
lot of advocacy for men I think for my
my stance is men need to be responsible
for the state of their lives